night two of the boys premiere ended  with straddling and some tasteful  kissing the final contestant of the  night kata hey blew the judges away with  her rendition of Gretchen Wilson's  redneck woman all of the judges turned  except for Blake I'm kind of  disappointed so we're just chopped liver  the 28 year old Oklahoma native  recovered by telling Christina you're my  official first girl crush should we just  make out now if you pick me there's more  of that to come and she did but the best  part of the whole thing for Elle's face  wake up wake up wake up wake up I'm cool  on this this is the dream so I just get  to do whatever I want it's like the  twilight zone I don't know what's going  on